pues este borrador es este el 10 de
febrero por eso varios analistas de
varias reacciones sacan washington dicen
que es preliminar que no es el documento
final y que también implicaría que los
jueces que en este momento apoyan ese
borrador podrían cambiar de opinión es
entonces un borrador del 10 de febrero
que ha generado mucha polémica porque es
la primera vez en la historia reciente
que se filtra en una decisión preliminar
de los magistrados de la corte suprema
de justicia antes de que se emita
precisamente este fallo que se daría en
cuestión de dos meses plus que apoyen
esta decisión son cinco de los nueve
magistrados el que escribió este
documento de 98 páginas que fue filtrado
anoche publicado por el medio político
muy activo y muy presente en la capital
y sobre todo en la corte suprema de
justicia pues son los siguientes dos
magistrados son miconi beret que fue
denominada por el expresidente donald
trump también está acabando el curso y
pues es samuel a nito además declarar y
tomar es el juez john roberts es el que
es de tendencia conservadora todavía no
se conoce cuál sería entonces su
posición una vez se tome la decisión
final sobre este documento que es de
insistir hay que resaltar es un
documento pues que es un borrador
todavía no está finalizado completamente
sin embargo argumenta que en ninguna
parte de la constitución y no en la
enmienda número 14 está el tema del
aborto en el en éste esta carta
institucional de eeuu